[dramatic music playing]
Mmm. Nice baps.
They're bagels, actually.
Can you not look at me like that?
-I'm your sister.
-Oh, yeah. Sorry.
Ooh, I feel Darth Baker is close by.
What do you think, Pruebacca?
[growls]
Yeah, you could be right.
[distorted heavy breathing]
I shouldn't have taken the stairs.
I'm knackered.
Too many lemon drizzles, mate.
[lightsaber whooshing]
[whimpering]
Oh! You just burned my pie!
It's fine. It's a little on the dark side.
-[chuckles]
-[robot beeping]
[Noel] Think my fruit sponge is ready.
Anyone?
No. I think you'll be
eating that flan solo.
[all] Welcome to
The Great British Baking Show.
You look a bit like
Billie Eilish's grandmother.
You look about four.
[Abdul] When I came in,
I could see the edges of the tent.
It's almost here.
I am just a few steps away.
I feel as though
I've fallen down a rabbit hole
and the Mad Hatter's gonna come
running around the corner. [chuckles]
[Sandro] I cannot wait
to walk into that tent,
feel what it's like
to be one of those people.
I've never wanted to be
in a tent so bad before. [laughs]
[Noel] From across Britain,
thousands of the best home bakers applied…
[Dawn] Good luck.
…but just 12 have made it.
I've always wanted to apply,
but never had the courage to do it.
This year, thought I'd give it a try,
and I'm here! [laughs]
I work in a supermarket
behind the checkouts.
This is the biggest thing
that I've ever done.
Things like this don't happen to me.
You just want to cry
because you cannot believe this is real.
[Noel] Over the next ten weeks…
It is going in.
…they'll face 30 brand new challenges…
Whoo-hoo!
…designed to put every bit
of their baking ability to the test.
[James] I've done baking
for quite a while.
I feel maybe I'm, like,
sort of good at this. [laughs]
We're about to find out how good that is.
Maybe I'm terrible.
My partner said,
"Fake it until you make it."
The stress is real.
And that's what I'm doing. [laughs]
[Matt] Everything they make
will be judged by Prue Leith…
It is utterly delicious.
…and Paul Hollywood.
I'm intrigued to see if Paul's eyes
are as blue as people say.
-Like a White Walker or something.
-[producer] They're bluer.
-Are they?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Look into your soul.
[Matt] They'll start
with astounding cakes…
-Come on.
-Oh, my! [coughs]
…a batch of scrumptious
signature sandwiches…
[Maisam] Oh, my gosh.
It's gone all crumbly.
[moaning]
-…a classic American cake…
-Yay.
…that'll catch some red-handed…
I was gonna high-five you,
but I've seen your palms. Good luck.
All right, can't stop.
…and a showstopping home bake…
-[clattering]
-[Abdul] Ooh.
[chuckles] It's okay. It's okay.
-It landed the right side up.
-[laughs] Yes.
…that'll expose any shaky foundations.
I'm so worried!
-[chuckling] Are you all right?
-Yes.
-[Paul] Boo!
-[gasps]
[laughter]
[opening theme music playing]
[Matt] After two years away in Essex,
we've pitched our tent back
in the beautiful grounds of Welford Park,
and our fresh crop of bakers
are about to face
three cake-based challenges,
after which,
one of them will be crowned Star Baker,
and one
will have to leave the competition.
Hello, bakers. Welcome to the tent.
It's time for your first ever
signature challenge.
Today, the judges
would love you to make a batch
of 12 identical mini sandwich cakes.
Yeah, you know,
like Battenberg in a panini,
Vicky sponge on sourdough,
tea loaf in a tuna melt.
That's a cake sandwich.
They're looking for sandwich cakes.
-Oh, good, 'cause they sounded rank.
-They did sound rank.
The shape and flavours
are entirely up to you,
you can use any sponge you like.
-You have one hour…
-What?
-…sandwiched between two half hours.
-Ah!
-You have two hours.
-You've got two hours. On your mark…
-Get set…
-Bake!
Whoo!
Right.
[Rebs] Little bit stressed,
I'm not gonna lie.
I just hope that today will go okay.
Doesn't feel real yet.
Two hours, it's not a long time
to make 12 sandwich cakes.
I didn't feel great this morning.
Really nervous.
It's crazy
because you're just making a cake,
and it's something you do all the time.
[Prue] Mini sandwich cakes.
This looks like quite a simple challenge,
but what we're really looking for
is a bit of originality.
[Paul] They can choose
any sponge they want,
but we want it small,
packed with the flavour,
full of their personality.
It's the first time
they'll show us what they can bake,
so this is really important.
We want to see their skills.
They need to be absolutely identical,
absolutely delicious.
Perfect sandwich cake is what we want.
[Paul] Morning, Rebs.
-Hello.
-Morning.
Tell us all about your mini sandwich cake.
I'm making
hazelnut mocha latte mini sandwich cakes
because I used to work as a barista,
and it's the drink my now boyfriend
used to order
when he was trying to chat me up.
[Noel] You're approaching this
like a barista.
In a way.
-These two will be absolutely pumped.
-The amount of coffee going in, hopefully.
[Matt] Rebs,
from County Antrim, Northern Ireland,
has been baking since she was three.
[Rebs] Come on!
Studying for a master's in business,
when she's not buried under books,
she's getting muddy with dogs
Miley, Ruby, and troublesome Tiggy.
-[Rebs] Oh, Tiggy.
-[barks]
[Matt] To bring the hazelnut flavour
to her coffee cakes,
she'll add chopped nuts
to her caramel filling
and highly caffeinated sponge.
-Have you practised this?
-Yeah.
What did your friends think of it?
Everyone has different tastes,
I'll say that.
[all laughing]
-You can get friends anywhere.
-Exactly! [chuckles]
This is a massive whisk.
[Matt] Rebs isn't the only baker
adding a kick to their cake.
[Abdul] Chilli powder
isn't to bring in chilli,
but helps bring in
the flavours of chocolate even more.
[Matt] A keen dancer,
software engineer Abdul
likes to Lindy Hop
with girlfriend Christine.
Hello!
[Matt] Born in Saudi Arabia
and living in London,
he's not seen his family
for over three years.
Technical difficulties.
[Matt] Containing raspberry jam
and mascarpone
between layers
of chocolate and hazelnut sponge,
Abdul's sandwich cakes
are dedicated to former friends.
I'm a huge lover of plants.
I have tons of them in my house.
I've killed a lot, unfortunately.
I'm trying to make these cakes
to pay tribute to those.
You're my favourite
botanical serial killer.
-You always hurt the ones you love.
-Yes.
-Come on, Abdul.
-Thank you.
I call this bite size of love.
[Matt] Sandro's bakes
also come from the heart.
When I first met my partner,
every time we met, I'd give a white rose.
So I'm making chocolate flower pots.
[Matt] When Sandro,
a fitness fanatic from East London,
isn't hitting the gym,
he works as a full-time nanny.
♪ I am the champion! ♪
[laughter]
[Matt] He'll fill his flower pots
with a chocolate and orange sponge
and a rich red wine ganache,
from which delicate sugar roses will grow.
Are you a gym guy? You look like you are.
-Twice a day.
-Once is not enough?
No, 'cause I'll do weights, isn't it?
And I'll do cardio.
Same. Can you tell?
[both laugh]
I do weights in a graveyard.
-The old bones. [straining]
-Oh, God.
Yeah. Forget cardio.
I haven't got a heart.
[chuckles]
[Noel] And it seems love is in the air.
These are mini Persian love cakes.
We've got a large
Persian community in our church,
so it's a tribute
to their faith and their friendship.
[Noel] Kevin lives
in Lanarkshire, Scotland,
with his wife, Rachel and their dog, Judy.
A talented musician,
he not only plays the clarinet,
flute and saxophone professionally,
but he teaches too.
Nice one.
[Noel] Kevin's love cakes
are full of Persian flavour,
with rose Swiss meringue buttercream
sandwiched between layers of pistachio,
almond, and cardamom sponge.
[Kevin] The sponge is going to have
blitzed pistachio nuts,
but I won't blitz them right down.
I want there to be
a bit of texture and crunch.
I'm using 120 grams of pistachio.
[Matt] Maisam's also chosen
to go all out with her nutty sponge.
I want to get as much flavour
and texture in the cake as possible.
[Matt] Born in Libya,
this year's youngest baker,
18-year-old design student, Maisam,
lives in Manchester with her parents,
two brothers, and younger sister Juri.
-I'm gonna copy your drawing.
-What?
[both chuckle]
[Matt] To help balance the sweetness
of her pistachio-packed sponge,
Maisam will fill her sandwich cakes
with raspberry jam
and raspberry Swiss meringue buttercream.
In the practice, it went really well,
so hoping
that it'll turn out well this time.
You're the baby here, did you realise?
I'm the youngest one,
so the pressure is on.
[Matt] Key to creating
delicious mini sandwich cakes…
Heavy on the coffee. Whoo!
…the judges will expect
beautifully flavoured soft sponge.
It's the blue-eyed one that scares me.
He's just super intense.
Like he's looking through my soul.
So disapproving! He looks at you like… Ah!
[Maxy] I nearly forgot to put my eggs in!
Oh, my goodness!
It's like, "Something's missing here."
[Noel] Swedish-born Maxy,
an architectural assistant
from southeast London,
is passing on her passion for baking
to daughters, Tyra and Talia.
[girl] That's enough now.
[Noel] She's giving her
Eton mess-inspired cakes a tropical twist
with mango and passion fruit coulis,
and mascarpone
between layers of vanilla sponge.
You're from Sweden,
but I can't hear the accent.
I've lived here for 21 years.
-A long time.
-You speak Swedish as well?
-I do speak Swedish.
-I'm semi-bilingual.
-Oh, are you?
-Mmm.
-What languages do you speak?
-English.
English and--
-No, I'm semi-bilingual.
-Semi! I'm sorry.
Oh, yeah! [laughs]
Next time I've got a joke,
I'll put it in writing
and send it to you in advance.
-Oh!
-Looks good. It is going in.
[Noel] The quicker
the sponges hit in the oven,
the longer they'll have to cool.
-Eleven minutes at 180.
-Is there a timer on this thing?
[Noel] If the bakers attempt
to cut and fill layers of sponge
while still warm,
they'll be left
with a crumbly, leaking mess.
Oh, crap! I forgot to switch it on!
Right, it's not done yet.
I can tell by visual clues,
i.e., it's not brown. [laughs]
[Matt] Will is a charity director
who lives in London
with wife Allison and three children,
Max, Verity, and Louis.
-That's going well, Louis.
-It's quite crumbly.
[Matt] To cut through the sweetness
of his salty caramel swirl buttercream,
and to stand out from the crowd,
Will's cakes contain no less
than three different types of ginger.
Who do you think's good?
Who are you scared of?
Uh, everybody. [laughs]
The first one,
you're just finding your feet, right?
New equipment.
Paul leering down on you.
It's not usually what happens.
No, normally, you just sit at home.
You haven't got a sort of tipsy posh woman
and a bronze man staring at you.
-You don't know where I live, do you?
-[both laugh]
[Matt] All right, guys,
I know you're new here.
Basically, the way
things work in this tent,
if you wanna know how long you got left,
you have to give us each a fiver.
Oh, well, it was worth a try.
You've got an hour left.
-An hour?
-Is that good or bad?
Bad for me.
I'm not confident about my meringues
'cause they have to go in for an hour.
-[beeping]
-[Abdul] That's a timer for my cakes.
They've risen very well.
More than I thought.
[Noel] The difference between
perfectly baked, moist sponge…
Oh, it's done.
…and a dry, dense disaster…
Oh, my! [coughs]
…can be a matter of moments.
It should be cooked.
You get the absolute fear.
These are sticky toffee pudding sponges.
Bit alarmed that one edge has sunk.
Don't know how that happened,
but I think it's okay.
Famous last words, isn't it?
[Matt] Originally from Glasgow,
James, a nuclear scientist,
has been baking
since he was five years old.
It's a passion matched
only by his love of '80s horror films.
That's incredible.
[Matt] He'll add warmth to his
sticky toffee apple sandwich cakes
with ginger in his apple jam
and nutmeg in his buttercream.
-Explain the colour of the kilt. Family?
-It's the colour I wore for my graduation.
Pants or no pants?
Er, that's for you to find out, isn't it?
-[laughter]
-That's an invitation.
[Matt] While their sponges cool…
I have a wee apple jam going.
…the bakers
turn their attention to fillings.
[Rebs] This is hazelnut caramel,
but I'm concerned 'cause it's a bit runny.
I probably put too much butter in.
[Will] I'm making
Italian meringue buttercream,
the technically complicated version
of buttercream.
[Noel] But Will's not the only one
trying to impress with ambitious icing.
Struggling to cut this butter. [laughs]
[James] The buttercream
is flavoured with rose.
I know rose can be
a really overpowering flavour,
so it's just a whisper.
Whoo-hoo!
[Noel] While Will, Maisam, and Kevin
attempt to sweeten up the judges…
Nice!
[singing indistinctly]
…Carole's gone sour.
Just making lemon curd.
I don't put that much sugar in
'cause I want it nice and tart.
[Matt] West country-born and bred,
Carole, a supermarket cashier,
lives in Dorset with husband Michael.
A keen gardener,
she's affectionately known
as Compost Carole.
Yeah, nice bit of root.
[Matt] As well as curd filling,
she'll add lemon juice to her buttercream
and zest to her lemon
and poppy seed sponge.
I'm a little bit of a classic baker.
Your carrot cakes and your lemon drizzles.
I'm not a big one for putting
exotic ingredients in, you know.
[Matt] But somewhere exotic
is exactly where Dawn's heading.
I'm doing lime and tamarind spring cake.
Tamarind, it's a slightly earthy flavour,
but it's fruity at the same time.
In this bake, it's fairly traditional,
but it's got a bit of a twist.
[Noel] Dawn, a former
project manager for Boris Johnson,
lives in Bedfordshire,
where she entertains granddaughter, Emmy,
with her hand-modelled sugar figurines.
Mr Froggington. Do you like him? Yes!
[Noel] To complement
her tamarind jelly filling,
she'll add coconut to her sponge
and create a coconut marzipan topping.
-You worked for Boris Johnson?
-Not directly.
-Did you get to meet him?
-Yeah.
His hair was a bit like yours, wasn't it?
[chuckles] I know, yes.
And his face was a bit like mine.
Yeah, there you go. We're like a hybrid.
[chuckling] Put us together
and you have Boris Johnson.
-How about that?
-Yeah.
[Noel] Dawn isn't the only baker
bringing a taste of the tropics.
I am making a Malaysian cake,
which is based on the pandan flavouring.
It is very aromatic.
People call it Asian vanilla.
[Matt] Malaysian-born Syabira
lives in London,
where she works in
cardiovascular research.
[Syabira] Comms check.
After work, she relaxes,
gaming online with boyfriend, Bradley.
-Oh, headshot. Oh, I got headshotted.
-[chuckles]
[Matt] Syabira will flavour her sponge
and coconut custard with pandan
and add caramel
to both her mousse and decorations,
traditional Malaysian sweets
known as onde-onde.
I'm going to make a caramel bomb.
When you bite into it, the caramel just…
-Explodes.
-…burst out.
[Noel] You're gonna
blow the judges' heads off. I love this.
-Good luck.
-[Paul] It sounds amazing. Thank you.
Good luck. Anyone who tries
to bomb these two is amazing in my book.
Thank you.
[Matt] But Syabira's caramel bombs
aren't the only bake
that should probably come
with a safety warning.
I'm soaking my sponges
with Polish cherry liqueur.
What I'm making today will be
a Polish-inspired bake, which is wuzetka.
[Matt] Janusz is a PA from Brighton,
where he lives with boyfriend, Simon,
and sausage dog, Nigel.
He learned many of his Polish recipes
from mum, Elizia,
who taught him and his sister to bake.
[in Polish] I always knew you like to eat
but I never knew you could bake so well.
[chuckles]
[Matt in English] Filled with
pistachio cream and cherries,
he'll top his boozy wuzetka
with a layer of rich chocolate ganache.
It's like a Polish Black Forest.
[Prue] Cherries soaked in booze.
-Thinking of you.
-[all chuckle]
-Thank you.
-[Paul] You've done your homework.
-I am glad to hear that.
-This sounds absolutely delicious.
My kind of bake.
-Good luck.
-[Matt] I want to do the time call.
-[Noel] My turn.
-No, it's my turn.
-Let me.
I'm doing the time call.
-All right. You do the time call.
-Thanks.
Bakers, you have half an hour left.
-Whoo!
-[Will] The sponge is done.
But my Italian meringue
split for reasons I don't understand.
So I'll make it again.
But Italian meringue buttercream
takes half an hour.
So it's slightly worrying.
I'm about to start cutting out the cakes.
[Noel] Whether they've baked
large trays of sponge…
I'm just going make small circles.
…or individual portions,
the judges will expect
every slice of the bakers' sandwich cakes
to be uniform and neat.
[Janusz] The tops will be cut.
They'll be even-sized.
A ruler.
I mean, most people wouldn't care,
but the judges aren't most people.
[Matt] The perfect slices…
It's very soft cake,
so I need to be careful.
…require a cool sponge.
[Maisam] Oh, it's gone all crumby.
I think I cut them
whilst they were still a bit warm.
[giggles nervously]
[Janusz] Now they need
lots of cherry vodka.
I've got my big guns here. [giggles]
Drizzle some more pandan flavourings.
Oh, my gosh. Hopefully, with the help
of buttercream, I'll manage to hide it.
[Matt] But there's a flaw
in Maisam's plan.
[Maisam] The buttercream
has curdled, yeah.
It'll take some time to fix it.
How long have we got left?
-Bakers, you have 15 minutes left.
-Oh.
Fifteen minutes.
I'm gonna start assembling.
[Maxy] We'll make it. We have to.
[Rebs] Ugh, this caramel
is starting to melt.
At home, I wouldn't care if the caramel
was over the edge. Now you're like, "Ah!"
[Syabira] Now, custard.
This is red wine ganache.
Hope it's strong.
[Maisam] Finally seeing
Swiss meringue buttercream,
[Matt] While Maisam's filling
comes together at last…
That was a nightmare. A nightmare!
Pulled it off.
It's done it again.
-…for the second time…
-[sighs]
…Will's has split.
Ugh, I need to make a buttercream.
How do I make a buttercream?
Butter? Sugar?
-Yeah.
[Carole] Decoration time.
Making bees. Fiddly little buggers.
[James] Just making the caramel
for the wee candles.
-Aren't you a nuclear scientist?
-Yes.
This is a come-down for you, isn't it?
You've got more important things
to be doing.
-Making cakes is more exciting.
-[chuckles]
[Abdul] These are cocoa nibs.
It's the soil.
-[Matt] Hello, petal.
-[Sandro] Hello.
-I was talking to the plant.
-Oh.
-[Will] Ooh!
-Bakers! You have five minutes left.
-Tight, tight, tight.
-I gotta get going.
Got to decorate the top, add my fruits on.
Terrified that I won't get this done
on time.
It's looking rubbish.
Think, William. Calm yourself down, mate.
I feel like I shouldn't be this calm.
I just wonder what's gone wrong.
[grunts]
I'm just very carefully
trying to put the coconut topping on.
[James] I wish the buttercream
was a tiny bit better.
[Rebs] Oh, this is not good.
They're just sliding.
What a freaking nightmare.
Finishing touches.
[Maisam] Flavour-wise, should be good.
But look-wise, 100% not happy with it.
It's not perfect, but…
I hope they will like it. I don't know.
These look amazing.
Is this your Persian business?
-Yes.
-Have you been to Persia?
-Uh, no. Maybe one day.
-We'll go together.
-Yeah?
-Yeah. You free on the 14th?
-14th of what?
-I've got to go do the time call.
-Goodbye.
-Okay.
Bakers, you have one minute left.
-[groans]
-Oh, my God.
Sixty seconds, kids. You can do this.
I'm going to try
as many cactus as possible.
[James] A very rushed nutmeg job.
[Maisam] I'm just trying to do
whatever I can do right now.
[Maxy] Don't collapse.
-[Noel] Bakers!
-No!
Your time is up.
[groans]
Please, step away
from your mini sandwich cakes.
[Sandro] Well done. High-ten.
That was a good high-ten as well.
There's Margaret,
there's Minnie, there's Maureen.
That's so cute! Yes!
[Dawn] Look at this.
[Kevin] Janusz, those are so neat.
[Will] It's rubbish. [groans and cries]
[Noel] For the very first time,
our 12 new bakers
and their mini sandwich cakes
are about to face the judgement
of Paul and Prue.
-Hello, Maxy.
-Hiya.
In your world, "mini" is a curious thing.
That's huge!
[Maxy chuckles]
Let's have a look at these monsters.
It's all over your fingers.
I can't take him anywhere.
I've got "mess" in the title.
-[Prue chuckles]
-[Paul] Yeah, exactly.
-The cake's quite dry.
-[Maxy] Is it?
Erm, you could have done
with slightly less bake on that.
Yeah.
But nothing wrong with
passion fruit sponge in a meringue.
The combination of flavours is beautiful.
-Well done.
-Yeah, well done.
-Thank you.
-[softly] Well done.
-[Maxy] Thank you.
Oh, my goodness.
[softly] Well done.
[sighs]
The pipe work, that's just like a blob.
What is that?
Who knows at this point? [laughs]
[Paul] See what the taste is like.
-Mmm! Beautiful!
-[James chuckles]
Absolutely sticky toffee pudding,
but better, because it's got ginger.
So we figured out you can bake
but you need to concentrate on the detail.
[Paul] They look great.
Love the decoration on the top.
[Prue] So cute. And I love the colours.
They're absolutely classic flavours.
Nicely balanced.
[Paul] There's enough lemon because you
get it through the curd also,
which is nice and sharp.
-[Carole] Yeah.
-What's not to like?
Thank you.
[Paul] They look very good.
Pretty consistent.
The rose is perfect.
Okay.
The cake itself is a bit heavy.
[Paul] You've got too much in it, which
will pull all the moisture from the cake.
So it's very dry.
Okay.
-[Prue] They don't look great, do they?
-No.
-[Paul] They're falling apart.
-I cut it when it was warm…
-Oh, fatal.
-…so it started crumbling a bit.
[Paul] The sponge is delicious
and the Swiss meringue is lovely.
Could have been sharper,
could've had more raspberry.
I don't think there's anything wrong
with the flavours. It just looks a mess.
[Paul] They look amazing.
I love the colour,
I love the pot, the soil.
-Thanks.
-[Paul] Just hope the inside
tastes as good as it looks.
I mean, that is really clever
to get all that in there.
The flavours are really punchy.
The red wine ganache works
beautifully well with the raspberry.
Oh!
[Paul] It's rich and indulgent.
-Well done.
-Thank you.
At first glance, you think,
"Absolutely delightful."
If you look closely,
there are a few problems.
They're a bit wibbly.
[Paul] The tamarind works really well.
Coconut works beautifully well with it.
-Overall, it's a really nice cake.
-[Prue] And it's original.
-Good.
-Well done.
-Thank you.
-[Paul] Yeah, nice one.
Abdul, I think it looks
absolutely delicious.
Thank you.
It's almost an illusion, which I like.
It looks like a garden.
Mmm! It's very light.
Little kick of chilli.
You get a little acidity.
I think the raspberry in there
is a beautiful flavour.
-I love the hazelnut.
-Thank you.
I'm impressed.
-Thank you, Abdul. Lovely.
-That went well.
-Better than I thought.
-Well done.
-Thank you.
-[Paul] Could be neater.
-[Syabira] Yes.
[Paul] Love the colours,
they're vibrant and in your face.
Mmm.
[Paul] The flavours
coming from the pandan,
the caramel, and coconut is delicious.
Such an interesting thing to do,
setting custard on top of a cake.
-[Paul] Gooey and unctuous.
-[Prue] Not too sweet.
-[Paul] Yeah.
-[Prue] Bomb time.
-[Matt] Can I nick a sugar bomb?
-Yes, feel free.
-That's amazing.
-[Matt] It's not too sweet.
I was expecting it to be.
But you do get the burst of sugar.
Look at me.
I'll have you two out of a job.
[laughter]
[Paul] Thank you very much. Thank you.
I liked it.
I mean, that counts for nothing
but I liked it.
[Prue] It looks like your caramel
was a bit runny.
Did you mean the caramel
to run right down the sides?
No. I spent ages trying to get the caramel
perfect, then it went… [giggles nervously]
There's enough coffee in there
to keep you awake at night.
[chuckles] Yeah.
Mmm.
The other flavours coming through
are not strong enough to compete with it.
And the ganache is too hard.
You're neat enough, I can see that.
Just be careful about your flavours.
-It's a bit… messy.
-[Will] Yeah.
My buttercream didn't go to plan twice.
-The curse of the tent.
-I feel the heart rate going now.
-Yeah.
Will, I think it's a bit… disappointing.
It's a bit bland.
There's ginger, but not enough.
There's a caramel undertone, but it's got
no hero, which is what you need.
Yeah.
-Besides that, brilliant.
-[laughter]
[Paul] Never mind, Will.
[Prue] That looks amazing.
It's neat as a pin.
Just has to taste good now.
Oh! It's lovely sponge. Very light.
-And boozy.
-Yes, that's how I like them.
To me, that's perfect. It is very boozy.
I think you've got too much booze.
That's the overwhelming flavour.
Texturally, it's perfect. It really is.
He's got a problem here.
Because I think the booze is perfect.
[laughter]
-Well done.
-Thank you.
-[Paul] Thank you.
-They're now stumbling back…
-I know. [chuckling]
-…out the tent.
[Janusz] I'm happy that it went well.
There was a lot of booze in my cake
because when I ate it,
I thought, "That's strong."
[Syabira] They like it.
They like my onde-onde.
It is very nice when people say
your food is good. [laughs]
It's interesting to have a disaster
in your first challenge.
Not my finest moment,
I think, it's fair to say.
[squawking]
[Matt] Each week, the bakers
will face a mystery second challenge
veiled by gingham.
[Noel] Hello, bakers.
Welcome back to the tent.
It's time for your first
ever technical challenge.
And your technical challenge today
has been set for you by Baby Paul.
-[Matt] Aw, sweet.
-Paul, any words of advice?
It's a classic.
Concentrate on your sponge.
[Matt] Well, as ever,
this task is judged blind.
So we ask Paul and Prue to leave the tent
where they are going to be
cryogenically frozen.
-[giggles]
-[Matt] Wrap up warm, kids.
So Paul would like you
to produce a red velvet cake.
-[gasps]
-Oh!
Your all-American layered cake
should make a big impression
on both the eyes and the palate.
I love impressions.
Matt's good at impressions.
In fact, he does an amazing Paul.
Go on, do your Paul.
You're a good baker, you're a good baker,
you're a good baker, too. All right!
[laughter]
[Noel] Cover your eyes and
it's like he's back in the tent.
Uncanny. Your classic cake should consist
of six tender, moist, crimson red sponges
sandwiching a smooth, fluffy
cream cheese icing.
Sprinkled with red crumbs
to give it that red velvet finish.
You have two hours
until we defrost Paul and Prue.
-On your marks.
-Get set.
Bake!
Obviously, my first challenge
was a disaster, so I'm stressed.
It's like anxiety.
[Matt] In the technical challenge,
the bakers are all given
the same basic recipe.
This is very sentimental.
This is the first cake I ever made.
[Sandro] I normally do a red velvet cake.
That's the curse. You're like,
"I know how to do that,"
and then this is the one day you don't.
I've never made one before.
[Prue] Paul, red velvet cake
for our first technical.
Why did you go for that?
[Paul] The advantage
is everybody will know it.
-It's quite a light chocolaty cake…
-Hmm.
…with the use of vinegar,
and buttermilk blended with bicarb.
There's your rising agent.
And actually, there's the flavour.
It has a very distinctive tang to it.
Obviously, there's colouring to give it
that vibrant red inside.
[Prue] Well…
[Paul] We haven't told the bakers
how much food colouring.
Adding too much
makes the cake far too dark.
And the proportion of cream cheese is
higher than in most sponges.
Yeah. It's a big cake.
We want height, so the thickness
of cream cheese is critical.
-It's lovely.
-I can't wait to see
what they're gonna turn out.
What I'm not looking forward to
is trying 12 red velvet cakes.
You're gonna have to stretcher me
out of there.
[Will] The first instruction is
"Make the red velvet batter."
No hints as to how.
God. What do we do?
Luckily, I've got it all in here.
[Syabira] I'm mixing my butter and sugar.
It's creaming up. That's what I want.
Now I'm going to add the eggs,
buttermilk, flour, cocoa, and vinegar.
Why are you putting vinegar in it?
What's that about?
Why would you ever put vinegar in a cake?
[Carole] A bit of a chemical reaction.
I think Diana Ross sang that.
[Matt] Combining vinegar,
buttermilk, and bicarbonate of soda
creates the bubbles crucial
to producing a light sponge.
I'll chuck in a bunch.
[Matt] But timing is everything.
[Dawn] You've got to add the bicarb
just before you put it in the oven,
because it doesn't last very long.
I'm just gonna wing it.
There's not really a method.
How red to make it is the question.
[Abdul] Crimson was the directive.
[Matt] What is crimson?
Does it mean light red?
Hers is a bit redder than yours.
-This is true.
-You could add a bit more.
I mean, I-- Don't ask me.
I've got no clue what I'm doing.
But then I'll blame you.
-Paul won't care. You know that.
-[laughs]
Right. Come on then, babies.
It just says "bake", at your leisure.
However long you want.
Ah! Sugar.
Those are being baked
for as long as it takes.
I think 25 minutes.
They're not very big.
I might give them 13 minutes,
and see how they're doing.
[Noel] Dawn, what are you doing?
-Who knows? It's an adventure.
-Sort of clattering stuff…
-I'm just… I'm just flinging stuff.
-[clattering]
[Noel] You've made
a red velvet cake before.
I have, but not for about 30 years.
-Whew!
-When my kids were little.
-Going back into the archives.
-It… Yes.
The trouble is, I was probably
under the influence of alcohol.
[laughing]
[Syabira] For red velvet cake,
it's very personal for me.
Before I left Malaysia,
my friends, we all sit down together,
all four of us,
having a very nice red velvet cake.
So I just made the last cake
that I've had with my friends.
Without them, I will never discover
my hidden talent to bake.
[Matt] Bakers, you are halfway through.
-Ooh.
-I don't want to put
any pressure on you guys,
but we're going to take
the best red velvet cake,
with the aid of a sewing machine,
I'm going to turn it into
skimpy briefs for us.
[chuckles]
I fail to see why that's funny.
"Make the cream cheese frosting."
There's no recipe. I'm just making it.
Ooh!
I'm just going to mix my cream cheese
and mascarpone together.
Then add double cream and whip it.
[Syabira] It should be fluffy.
Yeah.
[Noel] Bakers must whip with caution.
[mutters]
Over whip, and their frosting
will become a runny mess.
Need to get this thick, man,
'cause it's not going to settle.
Ooh, boy, that is liquid.
It's got to be like this where it can lift
and it's made a gloss.
Yeah. This is like
a perfect cream cheese here.
[groans]
Uh… Take a little bit longer.
So it's a waiting game.
-They're taking forever to bake.
-[Rebs] They're taking so long.
[Abdul] Giving me anxiety, just waiting.
Kevin, does it annoy you
that there's another Scottish person?
'Cause it annoys me,
and I'm not even Scottish.
[Kevin] He's wearing a kilt.
He kinda out-Scottished me.
-He has out-Scottished you, hasn't he?
-Yeah, yeah.
You know him?
I assume you all know each other.
[Kevin] We're from the same county.
-[Matt] Yeah?
-We had
the same saxophone and clarinet teacher.
[Matt] There you go.
Hi, Andy.
Hi, Andy. How you doing?
Haven't they done well?
You've taught them so well,
they're baking cakes instead.
[laughs]
[Carole] Oh, I don't know.
No, it ain't ready.
This cake hasn't readied yet.
I'm worried if I open the oven now
it'll go…
All right, mine have to be done now.
Oh, some are ready.
Oh, this is not good.
They've pure sunk. [exclaims]
Nightmare.
The cake just wasn't cooked long enough.
The change of temperature from the oven
to the cold here.
I'm just gonna have to go with it.
[Matt] Bakers, you have half an hour left.
Also, bakers, remember as hard as it is
to make a red velvet cake,
-I've actually made a red velvet coat.
-[laughs]
-Come on, then, babies.
-My sponges are ready.
Smooth.
[Syabira] I'm very pleased.
Ooh, yeah, I'm happy with that.
It's calmed down my nerves.
Maisam is slowly coming back.
[Maxy] That looks weird.
I don't know if it's moist or undercooked.
Janusz, was gonna high-five you,
but I've seen your palms, they're too red.
Good luck!
"Slice each sponge in half horizontally."
"Remove the bowl of icing from the fridge
and put it together."
[Matt] To achieve the height
the judges expect,
their frosting must be
the perfect consistency…
-It's a bit liquidy, I think.
-…and generously applied.
I'm trying to make proper, even layers.
I just want to try to get the height,
like, a proper big one.
[Dawn] "To decorate,
neatly coat the cake."
[Janusz] I would rather
do something different.
I'm going for a semi-naked
look, definitely, for this one.
You can go for that distressed look.
"A sprinkle of the leftover crumbs
around the bottom edge."
They're going to be fairly scant crumbs.
Pipe eight rosettes.
-[Syabira] Nearly there.
-My icing is melting.
Oh, man. It will be a blob of rosette.
[James] Going mad with piping.
Trying to show off.
I want this presentation to be like,
you know, up there. [laughs]
Bakers, you have one minute left.
-Ahhh!
-Crumbs, crumbs, crumbs.
Oh, blimey.
Please, please, please, please.
It is scary.
-Ahhh!
-Focus.
Bakers, your time is up.
[Rebs] Oh, this is not good.
Breathe! [sighs]
[Syabira] This is the height that I want.
[laughs] Done.
[Janusz] I can see that everyone
is going for a different style.
You cannot tell at the moment
who has the right idea.
That distressed look
is a decision I may well regret.
Oh! This is scaring me, like…
Sandro's decoration's immaculate.
[Rebs] That's really sunk.
I'm so annoyed.
Bakers, please bring your velvet cakes
down to the tablecloth.
Put them behind your photograph.
[Will] The gingham altar of doom.
[Abdul] Oh, man, my icing is melting.
-Oh.
-I don't know.
D'you know what I'm really intrigued by?
The different heighth.
[Rebs] Yeah. Syabira, yours is well tall.
[Matt] Paul and Prue are expecting
12 tall red velvet cakes
coated in fluffy cream cheese frosting
and decorated with a sprinkling of crumbs.
They have no idea whose is whose.
Oh, God.
Okay. Starting over here.
It is smooth,
-but it's not that tall, is it?
-Hmm.
[Prue] Cuts nicely.
Not much cream cheese filling
in there, is there?
Cream cheese
should be almost equal to the cake.
To keep that height.
Tastes good.
Soft with a little bit of tartness.
-[Paul] Moving on to number two.
-Piping is good.
[Paul] But the crumb on the outside,
it's too thick.
The flavour's all right.
Certainly got the tang to it.
[Prue] Right. Over here.
-This one's really attractive.
-[Paul] Hmm.
But I think the cake
is slightly undercooked.
And I also think there's quite
a lot of red in this one.
It's very red.
[Matt] You asked for crimson.
It's the wrong shade of crimson, Matt.
All right? Back off.
[laughter]
Okay, moving on. Not much height to it.
Needs to be a bit higher.
-And it's not very light.
-[Prue] It's solid.
That's a little bit claggy.
Feels slightly underdone.
-[Prue] Right.
-Now this is
almost the naked cake
around the outside, isn't it?
Very little cream cheese.
[Prue] But sponge is nicely risen.
[Paul] Yeah.
The sponge is light and tangy.
[Prue] So we have this one.
This is quite original.
Decoration looks like a wedding hat.
I don't like that. Cream cheese should
have been put in the layers.
That's why we've lost quite a bit
of height through that.
-Sponge is all right.
-Hmm.
Sponge is all right.
Just not what we wanted.
[Prue] Right. This one over here.
It's lost its definition.
Rather flat rosettes.
But certainly got the tang to it.
[Prue] Hmm. Nice flavour.
[Paul] Okay, moving on.
Could be a bit straighter.
[Prue] Yes, it's a bit on the lean.
But the sponge is all right.
-You get that lightness.
-Hmm. This is a good cake.
This one's got much too much
crumb on the bottom.
-[Paul] It has.
-Decoration doesn't look great.
Sponge, it's actually not that bad.
I just think I'd liked to have seen
that a bit neater throughout.
[Prue] Right. This one.
[Paul] Big layers of sponge.
The sponge is light.
[Prue] But the rosettes
sank all over the place.
I do hope that's as good on the inside
as it looks on the outside.
Height of the cake is good.
-Definition is perfect.
-This is what we were looking for
with the crumb, that light dusting.
[Prue] It's gotta be good inside.
-[Paul] This better be good inside.
-[chuckles]
-[Prue] Nice layers.
-There is a lot of cream cheese there.
Oh, that's very nice.
-That's it.
-Should we go home now?
[all laughing]
[Paul] Okay, moving on to this one.
A little bit too much on the crumb.
-It's neat, though.
-[Prue] Hmm.
I do like the sponges.
-Hmm. And got a nice zing.
-Mmm, absolutely.
[Noel] Paul and Prue will now rank
the red velvet cakes
from 12th to first place.
In 12th place, this one. Who is that?
James. We didn't like the decoration much,
and there's not quite enough cream
in the middle.
In 11th, we have…
Rebs.
Basically, very claggy.
In tenth place, this one.
Maxy, it was undercooked.
Ninth, we have this one.
Will, it's all over the place.
Fair enough.
[Matt] Carole is eighth. Janusz, seventh.
Sixth, Abdul. Maisam, fifth.
Kevin is fourth and Dawn, third.
We're getting close now.
In the second place…
Who is this?
Sandro. Could be a tiny bit higher.
But it's a really good cake.
Thank you.
So in first place, we have…
Syabira, that's fantastic.
Thank you.
My heart just melts. [laughs]
-Thank you so much.
-[indistinct chatter]
Well done, Syabira.
[squeals]
If I'm upset, I'll cry.
If I'm happy, I'm crying.
I am happy with second.
Yeah. Second is
kind of first, innit? [laughs]
It wasn't the worst,
but I know I've got a lot to do tomorrow.
It was a disaster.
Like, I'm just lucky I wasn't 12th.
But there's still another bake.
I will pick myself back up
and make sure my cake's
flippin' well-cooked this time.
[Matt] Just one challenge remains
before this year's first
Star Baker is crowned
and the first person
to leave the tent is revealed.
So what do we think of these new bakers?
Overall, the standard's been good.
-[Matt] Yeah.
-[Paul] But…
I think a few people, it got to them.
Rebs, Will is in trouble.
-Maisam.
-She had a tough signature, didn't she?
-Yeah.
-So who's in line for Star Baker?
[Paul] I think the likes of Abdul, Janusz.
-You know who else? Sandro.
-Sandro is amazing.
-[Prue] Technically tremendously good.
-[Noel] Calm as well.
He's calming me down
and I'm not even in the competition.
[Paul] And Syabira's incredible.
That technical challenge
was actually better than mine.
I mean, it's not that hard to believe,
is it?
Unbelievable.
When's the last time you baked,
Paul, in the '70s?
-Last week.
-[Matt] What did you bake?
-Blueberry muffins.
-Ooh, lovely. Nice.
As good as Syabira's?
Of course. I was like this. Well done.
[all laughing]
Hello, bakers. It's time for your
first-ever showstopper challenge.
And today the judges would love you
to make a stunning 3D replica
of your own home, entirely out of cake.
Your showstopper should look like
somewhere you have lived
which has special meaning to you.
It needs to be so good,
that Paul can live inside it for a week.
He's basically having
his bathroom renovated.
-He needs somewhere to crash.
-[laughter]
You have four hours.
-On your marks.
-Get set.
Bake.
Oh, it's so quiet in here. Concentration.
[scatting]
[Rebs] Yesterday wasn't my day,
but today's gonna be my day.
I want to just show them that I am
a better baker than claggy cake.
[Prue] This is their first showstopper,
and it's a home bake.
A bake of their home.
It could be anything.
A cottage, a block of flats, a bungalow.
But I want detail.
We want the pebbledashing,
and the ivy floating up the sides.
We want the window frames.
And of course, the most important thing
is that it's solid.
We don't want the roof blowing off.
We don't want the walls falling down.
[Paul] We want to see 12 fabulous homes,
looking amazing and tasting even better.
[Paul] Morning, Dawn.
-Hello, Dawn.
-Morning. Morning.
Tell us all about your home bake.
So my home bake is my nan's house.
-Did you live in it?
-I was born in it, actually.
And so was my mum.
It's a three-bed semi
and it's pebbledashed.
[Noel] Dawn will recreate
her nan's pebbledash from praline,
while inside, apricot puree
and German buttercream
will be sandwiched between layers
of delicate genoise sponge.
-So it's 12 layers, freestanding.
-Oh.
Interesting that you're using genoise,
which is notoriously quite a soft thing
with 12 layers with heavy cake.
-Yep.
-Interesting. Good luck.
-Thank you.
[Noel] Dawn is not the only baker
inspired by memories of their nan.
[Sandro] When we were younger,
we'd go there for Christmas.
There'd be, like, about 70 of us.
It was, like, my best childhood memories.
[Matt] Sandro will build
his grandparents' home
from strawberry sponge,
which he'll soak in strawberry liqueur
for some extra Christmas spirit.
We used to leave our Christmas parties
with bin bags full of presents
when we were younger,
and now I can barely get socks.
-[Noel laughs] Just socks.
-Grandparents,
-if you're listening to this…
-I know.
-Presents get worse as you get older.
-Yeah, they do get worse.
I can't afford socks?
That's what you are saying to me?
[laughs]
[Matt] And it seems
the festive cheer is spreading.
I'm using Polish ginger,
spices, and oranges
in my chocolate cake.
Because what is a better time to go
and visit your mum than Christmas?
[Matt] Janusz spent many
a happy Christmas in Poland,
and it's his mum's flat he'll recreate
from rich chocolate sponge
and spiced orange buttercream.
Colourfully decorated
to bring her garden balcony to life.
It was a very sad block of flats,
but I could always tell where my mum is
because it was the only balcony
where you could actually see flowers.
[Kevin] So this is the final cake mix.
I couldn't get a bowl big enough.
I think it's a two-spoon job. [laughs]
[Noel] Building a showstopper this big…
In total, there is five kg of batter.
I'm making a house, right? [laughs]
…requires a sponge
that not only tastes great…
I'm adding soy sauce instead of salt.
It makes it more rich, umami-flavoured.
…but is sturdy enough to support
the weight of their construction.
-Come on.
-[Will] This is a Madeira cake.
A proper structural cake.
I'm not particularly concerned
about the sponge.
It's pretty stable.
It's a banana cake. It's my mom's recipe
that I've tweaked a little.
[Noel] With a roof and windows of biscuit,
Kevin's childhood home will contain
fresh banana and maple butter cream
between layers of his mom's
pecan-packed banana bread.
[Kevin] I haven't chopped them too finely
'cause that could dry out the sponge.
And I do like a bit of texture, I do like…
Nice big nuts.
This is coffee and walnut.
Who doesn't like coffee and walnut,
unless you don't like coffee
or are allergic to nuts.
I am making a replica
of my little bungalow.
[Matt] Carole will build
her beloved bungalow
from another of her favourite
classic cake recipes, coffee and walnut.
But instead of adding real coffee
to her buttercream and sponge,
she's opted for a retro replacement.
It's chicory. It's when
you couldn't get coffee, I think.
Maybe when the war was on, I'm not sure.
[laughing] You smell it, can't you?
That'll put hairs on your chest.
-[Abdul] Okay, going in.
-[Noel] With so much cake to bake…
Done. And the sponges can go to the oven.
…the quicker their sponges go in…
Off you go.
…the more time to cool and cut them.
[Rebs] I'm making them thinner,
because then they cook
quicker and cool quicker.
[Noel] Any attempt
to build their homes from warm sponge
will result in a subsidence nightmare.
I'll remember to set the timer today.
[Noel] But Will's making life
difficult for himself.
I'm also making a chocolate cake.
It's slightly drier,
which could be good for the structure.
[Noel] After a disappointing first day,
Will's looking to impress
by constructing his old North London flat
from two sponges,
one chocolate and one orange,
with architectural details
made from gingerbread.
-Gingerbread, sponge, orange.
-Oh, my goodness.
Lots to do.
Hopefully, you can get away with it.
-Thank you, Will.
-I know. [laughs]
[Matt] Nearby, in southeast London,
is the flat where Maxy grew up.
[Maxy] It's my mom's block
where I started baking.
Flavours are inspired
by a family favourite,
which is my mom's apple and berry crumble.
[Matt] Maxy will spread her mom's
famous apple and berry compote
with a crumble topping
between layers of cinnamon sponge.
Enjoying your time here?
I am. I just get a bit stressed sometimes.
Are you scared of Prue or Paul more?
-Paul.
-[Noel] He's got a tough exterior.
-Like a crusty roll.
-[both laughing]
He's like a crusty bap,
but when you break him open…
-Yeah.
-…he's all soft inside.
-You see?
-And he's good
toasted with a bit of butter.
-[laughing]
-So…
-This has gone weird, innit?
-This?
-This conversation.
-The conversation. [laughs]
[sighs] How are you looking, cakes?
[Syabira] Double checking if it's cooked.
Yep, shouldn't be too dry. [groans]
[Janusz] Taking my small sponges out.
They all seem ready.
Oh, I hope it's cooked.
God.
I don't wanna overbake it.
Just want it to be perfect.
[Rebs] Letting the sponges cool
for as long as I can.
Oh, no, my oven wasn't on.
[chuckling] Oh, flippin' hell.
My oven wasn't on for the past 40 minutes.
[Matt] If Abdul
can bake his sponges in time,
he'll build his grandparents'
home in Pakistan
with mango and saffron jam
sandwiched between layers
of masala chai spiced sponge.
Cooling and everything is now challenging
because I've lost 40 minutes.
But keep going,
keep going and trying, right?
[Matt] Syabira's also hoping
to tempt the judges with a cuppa.
Milk tea is something we drink
all the time in Malaysia.
[Matt] And in a bid for top spot…
Cushty.
…her cake contains not just one,
but two types of tea.
Milk tea is the main flavour
that I want to bring in,
and matcha complement milk tea.
[Matt] Filled with strawberry
and cinnamon jam and matcha buttercream,
Syabira's milk tea sponges will form
the childhood home and tropical garden
she loved to play in growing up.
I can't imagine where you lived.
Somewhere fantastical.
-No.
-In a shoe? A golden shoe?
I lived in a village, very small
little house with coconut tree around it.
-[Noel] Wow.
-We tried to climb the coconut
because we thought if monkey could do it,
we also could. [laughing]
[laughing]
I can tell this is going to be
my favourite chat of the day already.
In theory, this is done.
[Noel] As Will's final sponge
exits the oven…
-There we go.
-[Abdul] Ooh, boy.
…closely followed by Abdul's…
-It's okay. [laughing]
-It landed the right side up.
[laughing] Yes.
Today is not my day, is it?
Cold, cold, cold, cold.
…the rest of the bakers
are ready to begin building.
They're cold enough to start stacking.
And, of course, the soak.
I'm going to be fairly generous with this.
Want it to be perfection.
[Sandro] Strawberry and cream liqueur.
I'm gonna add all of it. Grown-up cake.
[Noel] But Sandro's grown-up cake
won't be drinking alone.
[Rebs] Plenty of coconut rum.
Whoa! That was hot.
During lockdown,
because we couldn't go anywhere,
me and my parents,
we just had, like, a cocktail night.
So, this is one of the ones
that went down a treat was a piña colada.
[Matt] Rebs plans to bring party vibes
to her house
with flambéed pineapple rings
and rum butter cream
sandwiched between layers
of a rum-soaked coconut sponge.
[Rebs] I need
to get the sponge right today
because I didn't
cook my sponge properly yesterday.
Oh, my goodness. You're joking.
My cake's not fully done.
-[Matt] But Rebs' party…
-They're not fully cooked.
…might be off.
Erm, I don't know
what I'm going to do. Erm…
I just need a minute to myself.
I feel like I'm gonna be sick.
[sighs]
[Matt] It was your turn
to do the time call,
and then I just spoke over you.
It was really out of order,
so I won't ever do that again.
-Do the time call.
-Really?
-Yeah.
-It's your time call.
-No. It's yours.
-You're giving it to me?
I'm giving you my time call.
Bakers, you are halfway through!
Sorry, I forgot. I forgot.
I would like to be carving cakes by now,
but I've still got gingerbread to make.
I think I'm gonna struggle with time.
[Noel] And Will's not the only one.
My sponge.
They've just not really fully cooked.
I don't know why.
[Noel] But Rebs has a cunning plan
to get back on track.
This one's okay.
I'll just take a ring of cake
from here and put it in.
Look, you'd never know.
It's fine, I won't panic, why would I?
Panicking's for losers.
-[Carole] Constructing now, layering up.
-[Maxy] This is going in, my crumble.
-Everyone's just bashing stuff.
-Yeah, it's not even in the recipe.
[Noel] Is that Paul or Prue?
-What one is it the same colour as?
-[Noel] It's Paul, isn't it?
-What's that?
-It's a butterscotch lattice.
That's what he takes to the tanning
salon and goes, "I wanna look like this."
[Maisam] Carole, look at this colour.
-Without food colouring.
-[Carole] Oh, wow.
This is my childhood house.
Back home in Libya.
[Matt] Taking inspiration
from her favourite lemon tree growing up,
Maisam will fill her
lemon sponge with blueberry jam
and add colourful decoration
to give the house the finish
Paul and Prue expect.
But if I just speed up a little bit,
then I can give them
that finesse that they want.
Oh, no! [laughing]
Small explosion.
[Noel] James, too, is inspired
by a childhood memory.
[James] My dad used to have a cottage
in Loch Fyne.
It's the first place
I remember getting terrified.
We watched Dracula, during which,
my dad wandered by
with an axe outside the door.
It was a 4D experience. [laughs]
[Noel] James' frightfully tasty cottage
will contain orange curd
and orange blossom buttercream
spread between six thick layers
of orange and cardamom sponge.
[James] It's oozing a tiny bit,
but surprisingly okay,
'cause it is a lot of weight on top,
but we'll find out.
Bakers, you have 30 minutes.
[Will] Definitely behind.
[Matt] While Will and Abdul
still construct their homes…
My plan's to just assemble this,
and I'll decorate it as much as I can.
…for the rest of the bakers,
it's a nail-biting race to the finish.
I'm trying to be neat.
I was overgenerous with the fillings,
so I've skipped a layer.
The only person that will notice is Paul.
I'm sure he'll count them all.
[Carole] This is sugar fondant.
[Sandro] If only it was this easy
to brick a house.
Roof under construction.
My dad was a roofer as well.
-[sing-song] Irony.
-[normally] What can I smell?
Yeah, I smell burning.
It's not me, is it?
[Kevin gasps]
A little bit overdone. [sighs]
[Dawn] Pebbledash.
I used to get told off,
when I was a little girl--
-Picking the stones off?
-Yes.
[Noel] This might tap
into Paul's childhood as well.
Not sure Prue
will identify with pebbledash. [laughs]
She won't have a clue.
-You haven't got a maze around your house.
-Or a moat.
-Got a gate.
-[laughing]
[James] The brickwork around the cottage,
I wanted to show
the higgledy pigglediness of it.
Time is a limiting factor right now.
[Maxy] I'll have to leave out
a lot of things, I think.
-[Matt] What'll you do with that?
-I'll eat it later.
-[Matt] Will you?
-Yeah.
What will you do with these?
One of the main issues
is the misuse of disused tissues.
[Maisam laughing] Embarrassing.
Bakers, you have five minutes left.
[laughing] The stress is real.
-[Carole] Come on.
-[Sandro] I have to give Christmas now.
The more detail, the better.
[Syabira] Nearly there.
Piping clouds out of Italian meringue.
-What is happening here?
-[Maxy] Er… It looks terrible.
Maxy, you're not on your own. [sighs]
I need another couple windows on it.
Hands are shaking.
All right, can't stop.
-[Matt] Wow.
-[Syabira] It's not what you think.
-[Matt] What is it?
-Coconut tree.
-Right.
-So I'm making the trunk… [chuckles]
Oh, right, okay, yeah.
I'm trying to use this barfi
to make sheep.
I can't watch you do that.
It brings back too many memories.
[laughing] I hope it's a good one.
Bakers, you have one minute left.
[whines]
This buttercream has split.
Don't even look like squares.
[Kevin] Better than the red velvet cake.
A step in the right direction.
Just some shimmer.
Bakers, your time is up.
Please step away from your bakes.
I feel so mean.
What kind of showstopper is this?
[Abdul] It's not as I pictured it.
[Carole] That is so, so good.
It looks incredible.
[Rebs] It's not very neat, but it looks
like my house, which is a bonus.
I just don't want to go home.
[Noel] It's time to judge
the showstopping home bakes.
Rebs, would you like
to bring your showstopper up, please?
-Jeepers, it's heavy.
-[Kevin exclaims]
[Rebs] Just one thing to get.
I don't know if you've ever been
to Northern Ireland,
but it's constantly raining,
so you have to have
a bit of coconut rum rain.
-I like the idea of coconut rum rain.
-[Rebs chuckles] I know.
It does remind me of a very rural cottage.
It's very good.
-[Prue] The detail's lovely.
-This is basically a piña colada cake?
[Rebs] Yeah. Coconut and vanilla sponge,
pineapple curd
and flambéed pineapple slices
with coconut and rum butter cream.
[Prue] Mmm.
I love the flavour.
[Paul] The pineapple
and coconut comes through.
It is overbaked, the sponge, not by much,
but overall, I think, A, it looks great,
B, the flavours came through beautifully.
Oh, my God.
-Well done, Rebs.
-Oh, good grief.
-Shall I take it away? Okay.
-[both] Yeah.
-Quit while you're ahead.
-[all laughing]
Thank you so much.
-Well done.
-[Rebs] Thank you.
I'm crying… [sniffs]
-[Prue] What are the windows?
-Sugar cookie filled with butterscotch.
-Did you mean to burn them?
-I didn't mean to.
[Prue and Paul chuckle]
The banana cake itself is delicious.
My only thing is,
cut your pecans up more, they're too big.
It's a really good cake.
[Matt and Noel] Well done.
It's beautifully neat Carole,
and the piping is beautiful.
[Paul] I love the pots around the outside.
[Carole] That's coffee and walnut
with coffee butter cream.
The coffee's powerful.
Yeah, it had a good glug.
[clears throat] It's really powerful.
[both laughing]
I've never had a coffee cake
that strong before.
-Nor me.
-Coffee's actually burning.
-[Prue laughs]
-That's fascinating. Wow.
You've blown Paul's mind.
[Prue] Lots of skill here,
you're very good at piping.
Thank you.
-[Paul] So much buttercream.
-[Prue chuckles]
It's very claggy.
[Prue] Especially
the compressed middle layer.
I think it's the weight.
There's so much buttercream on there.
The sponge just can't hold it.
It glues your mouth,
which might be a good thing for you now.
But the flavour's fantastic.
You obviously ran out of time,
the piping's a bit clumsy.
-[Paul] Let's have a look. Hmm.
-[Prue] Ooh, wow.
[Paul] Never had a crumble
in a cake before.
I think you've done a really good job.
The crumble with the compote,
it's just fantastic.
It works really well.
-[Matt and Prue] Well done.
-Thank you. [laughs]
I was so worried.
-Are you all right?
-Yeah.
-[Paul] Boo!
-[gasps]
[all laughing]
[Paul] You've lost detail on the house.
-[Abdul] Yes.
-You ran out of time?
Unfortunately, my oven wasn't hot,
which meant my cakes were delayed.
So that pushed everything.
My sponge is masala chai,
and in between
I have mascarpone frosting and mango jam.
The chai's delicious,
carries really well inside the cake.
I think the bake's good too.
It's delicious,
but I would have liked more mango.
-Okay.
-I'd like more detail,
because I think inside tastes great.
It looks absolutely charming. I love it.
I like the pebbledash.
It's gone wonky,
but I'm thinking the house was wonky.
-Subsidence. Terrible subsidence.
-[Noel laughs]
-[Paul] Wow.
-[Prue] Look at that.
It's genoise sponge with apricot, praline,
and vanilla German buttercream inside.
-[Prue] How many layers?
-Supposed to be 12.
I'm going to be really honest
and admit that there are 11.
[Prue] It's really brave
to make genoise so airy
that it could get squashed easily,
but it hasn't squashed at all.
[Paul] That is a fantastic cake.
You've got texture from the praline.
The apricot is lovely, with some tartness
to that, which really works.
The sponge is well baked,
the butter cream works well.
[Prue] Well done.
I like the whole look of it.
It's charming.
[Paul] The detail's lovely.
This has got a lot
of interesting flavours, yeah?
[Syabira] It is milk tea sponge
with strawberry jam
and matcha buttercream.
[Paul] Cuts nice.
Your textures are beautiful.
The baking element is perfect,
those sponges are delicious.
My issue is, there's no hero flavour.
There's so many little things going on,
there's matcha,
the strawberry, the tea flavour
is not strong enough.
Oh, my God, I recognise that block now.
-[Matt] Really?
-Yeah, we live near each other.
That's brilliant.
[Noel] So good.
-[Paul] You've over baked every one.
-[groans]
[Paul] The chocolate
could have been more punchy.
Love the orange,
but it comes down to the bake for me.
It's not perfectly decorated, is it?
It's a little bit clumsy.
-[Paul] Let's have a look.
-[Maisam] It's lemon,
which is inspired
by the lemon trees in that house.
[Prue] Mmm.
It's quite dense.
But I actually love the flavour.
[Prue] It is just a bit puddingy.
That in a bowl with custard,
I'd be in heaven.
-But this is supposed to be cake.
-[both laugh]
Like the flavour, texture's wrong.
-Bit simple on the decoration.
-Yes.
The decorations are quite sweet,
but I expected that to be
a lot more detailed than it is.
It's just a little bit simplistic.
But his grandparents
actually lived in a cake,
so it's actually very accurate.
[Paul] Yeah.
-[Noel] Wow!
-[Matt] Look at that.
[Prue] Well, there's
lots of strawberries and cream.
Doesn't bowl me over.
-There's too much alcohol.
-[Prue] Do you know?
-Too much?
-I thought I'd never hear me say this,
but he's right.
Sponge is lovely and soft,
but somehow,
if you put booze in a filling,
it's modified by the cake,
but if it's in the cake, it's everywhere.
I love it for the colour and the vibrancy.
[Paul] The decoration and the pipe work,
amazing job.
This looks beautiful, this area.
I can see coming home to your mom's flat
must have been really good.
[Janusz] It is chocolate cake.
-It contains soy sauce.
-[Prue] For the umami?
That's correct. And inside,
Christmas-inspired buttercream.
It is utterly delicious.
Just the right amount of spice,
very chocolatey.
The textures and bakes are delicious.
-I can't fault it. Excellent.
-[Janusz] Thank you.
-Well done.
-[Noel] It's a work of art.
Janusz, well done.
Yeah, that's amazing feedback.
If I was named as Star Baker,
that, in my heart, would
be like winning the competition
because cake is my favourite.
They say the cake looks lovely,
but it doesn't have a punchy flavour.
Yeah, it's fair. I know I made
a boo-boo that way.
[laughing]
[Will] Could have been worse.
But, you know, I still feel
I'm languishing a bit along the bottom.
[Maisam] I'm in danger.
To be honest, I don't know
whether I've done enough to stay.
[Rebs] I'm very happy. That went as well
as it possibly could have done.
Just hope it's enough
to be not bottom anymore.
[Matt] Prue and Paul
have made their decision.
It's going to be okay,
it's going to be okay.
I hope so.
I've got the great job this week
of announcing the Star Baker,
and this week's star Baker is…
Janusz.
[all cheering and applauding]
[Carole] Well done, well done.
If it was up to me, I'd keep you all here
and send one of the judges home.
Sadly, it isn't up to me,
and we do have to say goodbye
to one of you, which feels very early.
But the person who is leaving us is…
It's Will.
[all groaning]
Guys, you go
and all knock it out of the park.
Will, you should
just feel proud of yourself.
-[Paul] Well done, Will.
-[Will] Thank you.
-[applause]
-[Maisam] Well done.
You know, somebody's got to go first,
and, obviously, I'm disappointed,
but I'm proud to have made it.
Yeah, I'm all right.
I knew it was going to happen.
I'll miss our conversations.
You know,
there's a lovely bunch of people I've met.
I've got an experience
I can talk about and share.
Yeah, I'm proud of that.
-[Paul] Bit better next week, please.
-I need to be a lot neater.
[sighs in relief] I'm still here.
I… I literally…
I can't believe it.
I was constantly hearing my name.
Next week,
I really wanna impress the judges
and also make myself proud as well.
[Paul] Well done, Janusz.
You absolute rock star.
Er, winning Star Baker on the Cake Week
means everything to me.
-I'm so pleased for you.
-Thank you.
Are you crying?
I've cried so many times.
-[Janusz crying]
-Is he crying? Oh, babe, babe.
My boyfriend will be proud.
And he will say, "You can make cake
and I've told you you can make a cake."
-[Maxy] Aw! Well done. Well done.
-[Janusz] Oh.
-[Maxy] First Star Baker.
-Thank you.
Hey, hon bon. I just wanted to tell you
that I've won Star Caker in the Bake Week.
-No! No, I win… No.
-[man laughing on phone]
[both laughing]
[closing theme music playing]